can you look at uh the tweet i just
tweeted some aggressive bitcoin buying
on coinbase what's going on this is this
is a trading light which is one of like
my favorite platforms and just so like
people know what's going on price action
like in the last like 10 minutes on the
top is obviously price and then those
little like scattered lines that you can
ignore that those are like the active
bids and asks on coinbase right now but
what you'll see in the middle is that's
the volume so there's those green bars
showing there's really high volume and
then at the bottom you see that the
green line that's cbd which is
cumulative volume delta it's showing you
is the price um you know the active
market price moving more towards the bid
or the ask so it's basically showing you
our buyers or sellers more aggressive in
the market and so you know that in
combination with volume is basically
showing you there's an aggressive buyer
on coinbase right now so that's that's
just what's going on in like the the
immediate term and so that's what's
driving kind of this quick price
increase is that there's some major
buyer on coinbase scooping up bitcoin
yeah oh yeah we call it t-whopping where
they're basically you know like
averaging in um you know a large buy
right you can't just fat thumb a large
buy
which by the way i mean speaking of fat
thumbing that price action yesterday was
pretty funny where we had someone
basically just like
market selling this really fat order
that liquidated like 46 million there's
47 million dollars of longs and then we
just continued right up it's a complete
scam price action it's been uh it's been
it's been some weird some weird pa over
the last two days yesterday like i said
we had that big seller and now looks
like we have some aggressive buying on
coinbase but yeah for listeners like
trading light is awesome you can go in
and look at per exchange uh basically
like this heat map of all the bids and
asks and then overlay some of these
other indicators but anyway we can get
into the newsletter i just wanted to to
i love that one on right the second
okay let's start with the future
perpetual funding rate what exactly is
this and what's it telling us
right so the funding rate is based on
the delta between
the spot price and um in the market
price which is you know different on
each exchange so you're looking at the
weighted average of all the spot
exchanges versus what the actual
perpetual swap contract price is trading
on
and so this what you're looking at is
the aggregated
version of this but what you want to
look for with funding is
not necessarily the fact i think there's
this misconception that when you have
positive funding that it's that it's
always bearish and that's not the case
because
it can just be the the price of doing
business at the time right if if the
market's trending bullish then that's
just the cost of doing business in a
bullish market and you know contrarily
you know if if you're in you know
bearish market this is kind of the cost
of doing business or if you have a large
liquidation cascade that can drive the
perp contract lower than spot um and you
can have negative funding where i think
funding is really a good tool is when
you have these dislocations between the
trend of it and price
and so really good example of this was
right after we broke all-time highs that
really big uh little cluster that you
see on the left-hand side that's
funding mooning up to like 150 apr and
some exchanges um which is you know
obviously a bit concerning in itself but
where you really would would be
concerned um was and that's that second
kind of spike on the right hand of right
hand side of that first cluster and the
reason is because price is grinding down
while funding is rising and so
essentially what that's saying is the
force that the perpetual swap you know
traders are exerting so their their
leverage longing as price is going down
so they're basically getting you know
getting faded by what the spot market is
doing and that's that's a huge red flag
and so if you remember a long time ago
like at the end of summer we called this
big short squeeze off the lows and this
is the complete opposite setup
price was rising funding was going the
opposite and so
using these dislocations can give some
good signal about what happens in in the
market
and over the last couple days on
wednesday i think it was wednesday night
um you had this another dislocation
where price was grinding down funding
was rising and that was a big big red
flag um you also had open interest
spiking and particularly uh in
particular the coin margin contracts so
we look at we talked about this last
week the coin margin uh versus the
stable coin margin and why you know why
there's more convexity to the to the
coin margin uh because you know as price
goes down you're not only you know your
p l is decreasing but you're less
collateralized so that's another another
thing to look at is the coin margin open
interest um you can also look at
liquidation levels so i'd like to look
at high block is a really good platform
for that you can see where the
liquidations are so you can say okay if
price goes down to you know x level then
you have a large cascade and so whales
can see this information too right and
so that's why you know you have things
like what happened yesterday where it
basically looked like someone was kind
of stop loss hunting in the sense that
they were trying to trigger a cascade
you know perhaps buy in cheaper or they
went short and then triggered the
cascade right um and so looking at some
of these things can kind of give you
some insight into you know when traders
are kind of getting offsides and when
they're in you know when they're
leveraged doing so um you know that that
was a that was like a pretty you know
red flag to me on on wednesday
but you know we flushed a bit of that
leverage out